Christopher Columbus was never paid what
he was owed by the Spanish Crown in fact
part of the reason they accused him of
all sorts of bogus crimes is to get out
of paying him what he was owed in as
much as Columbus did undertake that
perilous voyage for wealth he did so in
order to fund a crusade to retake the
Holy Land the pilgrims of the Mayflower
gave up not one but two lives of
relative Comfort one in England and
another one in Leiden in the Netherlands
which was their adopted home after they
got to America half of them died before
the first winter was through George
Washington lost half of his net worth in
the revolution John Adams faced major
financial problems throughout the war
problems that he could have fixed had he
not continued to serve in the
Continental Congress Thomas Jefferson
died a debtor and that debt grew in
large part due to his 40 Years of public
service for virtually all of history
mere acquisitiveness sufficed to justify
Wars of Conquest but ironically the men
that the leftists call thieves and
plunderers were all motivated by higher
ideals